[موسيقى]
سالنا الناس لماذا تنفق الفتيات اموالا
سائله على الاحذيه الرياضيه الفاخره نتابه
صبحكم الله بالخير اهلا وسهلا فيكم
مشاهدينا احدثكم من احد المجمعات التجاريه
بالرياض واللي يتواجد فيه اغلب البراندات
العالميه سؤالنا اليوم موجه للشباب
والفتيات والسؤال ليش برايك الشباب او
الفتيات يقتلون الاحذيه الغاليه راح ناخذ
اراهم في هذا المكان خليكم معنا
[موسيقى]
اتوقع الاغلبيه يقول يشترون حدى مريح مهما
كانت التكلفه عشان يكون يعني مرتاح سوا
رياضي يكون يعني بيشتغلوا في الرياضه
والحين كلها
في نفس الوقت يعني شكلا يليق بالراجحي
طول معك عمر افضل جوده هتكون عاليه فوق
كذا مريحه لانه
مرات اطيحه للرجل
في القناه
[موسيقى]
مالها جوده رخيصه مالها جوده
بس شو اسم الغاليه له جوده وحلوه بالنسبه
لي الافضل امتصاص الشعر
عادي بس بعد سنه وسنتين خلاص ما اشوف شيء
حلو
فالبران صراحه 10 سنوات
رخيصه انك تاخذ الراحه همم بتقدر تتاكد من
كل اللي تتبعها ممتاز بتقدر تاكد انه حتى
ما تتلف معك مع الزمن بس
تبعها هي همم راحت الحذاء